- [Instructor] So we've spent
a lot of time justifying
why we have this downward-sloping
demand curve for money.
But you're probably asking,
well, this is a market, what,
we didn't think about
an equilibrium point.
And to do that, we need to
think about the supply of money.
And in previous videos,
we've started thinking
about the supply of money,
and we'll think more in future videos
about different monetary policies.
But in a classical model,
we assume a perfectly
inelastic supply of money.
So we draw it as a vertical line,
which is another way of saying
that the supply of money
is not impacted by the
nominal interest rate.
So this is the supply of money.
I'll call that money supply one.
Where it intersects the quantity of money,
I'll just call that M
sub one right over here.
And so this point where it intersects
is the equilibrium point
in our money market.
The equilibrium nominal
interest rate right over here,
we could call R one.
This would be the opportunity
cost for holding money.
Now I have to give a
little bit of a disclaimer.
This is a classical model here,
and we'll talk more about
it in future videos.
And most introductory economics class
talk about this classical model
where the central bank might
set the supply of money,
and that doesn't change according
to the nominal interest rate.
And then the nominal
interest rate gets set
essentially by this equilibrium point.
Now, in the world that we live in,
it actually goes the other way around.
Central banks actually target
a nominal interest rate.
And if the central bank is able
to achieve that target interest rate,
well, that's going to impact
the actual quantity of money.
So keep that little disclaimer
in the back of your mind.
But in an introductory economics class,
we assume this world.
So now that we have this neat little model
for our money market,
let's think about what would
happen in different situations.
Let's think about a situation
where, for whatever reason,
people lose confidence
in the electrical grid.
What would happen to the
demand curve for money?
And let's call this the MD sub one.
Pause this video, and think about it.
Well, if people lose trust
in the electrical grid,
then this precautionary motive
for holding money becomes stronger.
Regardless of what the opportunity
cost is of holding money,
people would want to
hold more of it because,
like, hey, you know, I
don't know if I'll be able
to access money if the
lights go out again.
I'm not gonna be able to go to an ATM,
or the banks are gonna close.
And so at any nominal
interest rate, I would
or, and in aggregate, people
are going to want to hold more money.
And so that would shift the
demand curve for money to
the right.
I could've drawn it a little
less hairy, but there you go.
That would be MD sub two.
We have this shift to the right.
And then if that happened,
if you had this demand for money increase,
well, then what happens
to the actual equilibrium
nominal interest rate?
If you look at this point right over here,
assuming that the quantity
of money has not changed,
you have a new equilibrium interest rate,
nominal interest rate.
It has gone up,
and that makes sense.
If more people want to hold money,
in order to get people
to part with that money,
you have to offer them more.
The opportunity cost of holding
that money has to go up.
And you could imagine
the reverse scenario.
If, for some reason, people
thought it's a lot less likely
that the lights are gonna go
out, or they said, you know,
I don't need as much cash
around for transactions
or I'm not really into speculation,
well, then the demand curve for money
would shift to the left.
And in that situation,
you would have a decrease
in the equilibrium nominal interest rate.
I will leave you there.
Always keep these models
with a grain of salt.
They're simplifications of the
real world, especially here,
where we're assuming a perfectly
inelastic supply of money,
which actually isn't the
case in the real world.
But we can go with this for just,
for the purposes of starting
to study the money market.